okay
my name's lovely story and i'm here to
as a last minute kind of request
to back on the excellent
presentation by sarah sweden on svg
to make a long story short sarah was
originally going to talk about shapes
and i was originally going to talk about
svg
and she got in and i didn't quite get in
but then she changed your mind
so i'm going to try and do a
accessory topic to that featuring a
little bit of my own work and talking
about
some of the things that sarah didn't
have time to address
but i would recommend that if you're
watching this now you go
see sarah's first so you can get the
basics from her
but i'm going to start off from just a
little bit of perspective
so i am dudley's story at dudley's story
on twitter
i have a blog called demosthenes.info
where i write about web development and
i'm a
by trade i'm a web development teacher
that's what i do
i teach full-time part-time night
classes
all the time that's what i do i'm also a
writer i
published through a press last year pro
css3 animation
and i'm also a contributing editor to
smashing magazine
i do their coding section so most of the
requests for
and authors of writers come for coding
at least come through me for smashing
magazine
so svg um
svg's been thought of and
debated and worked through
as a kind of
very often as this foreign thing this
foreign
not terribly understandable um
kind of battle against css
and it's really not right we really
shouldn't think of svg and css as being
enemies or even being frenemies
they really are um two parts the same
side so don't think of them as battling
each other just think of them as one
tool that's
like a kick-ass lightsaber um that's
essentially the join together i'll show
you ways in which
both css and svg and ultimately html
can really start to complement each
other they're not
oh it's only just the svg or it's only
just css the two really do start to work
together in very interesting kinds of
ways
so i'm going to give a very quick little
breakdown of a couple of things that
people need to do again
sarah covered a little bit of this but
i'm going to do a an addition
some of this is again from my blog but
we'll give you
urls
so adobe illustrator workflow for svg
production
so very quickly um
if you know and most people will be
using
adobe illustrator to get some sort of
work out
if you know that you're going to be
using
adobe illustrator for export to svg
then there's a couple of things that you
do want to do
you'll want to set up your canvas in
pixels and that seems kind of weird
at the first because svg is meant to be
the scale free
doesn't matter what kind of units you
use and that's true
but it's easiest if you set up canvas
first in pixels because it's the easiest
thing to relate to
it doesn't mean that your svg is limited
to a certain pixel
dimension don't get that in your head at
all but it does
help move things across work out where
components are that sort of stuff
the artboard that you make so whatever
size of artboard you want to make is is
perfectly fine
but the artboard is going to become the
view box
of the svg essentially although vue box
does a lot of things in svg
essentially that's the visible area of
your svg
so if you want to do things off canvas
that's perfectly fine just make sure
that your
your art your artboard is a certain size
but if you want to make it larger later
that's perfectly fine as well just be
aware that the two
will by default match up in illustrator
again you can change them
svg again in illustrator will set itself
up for cmyk
don't make the mistake that generations
of people have made
when using these tools and set it up for
cmyk when you really want rgb
in most cases so make sure it's rgb
the thing to remember about making
components in illustrator is
that as you make them the way that i
like to think about svg is you're making
drawings as data
you're not just making pretty lines
you're not just making curves
you're making drawings as data so as you
build things give them some sort of
naming convention
get any kind of naming convention is
fine as long as you're consistent and
you stick to it
so stick to building something and name
everything as you build it while it's
not absolutely necessary to do so it
becomes a whole lot easier later
when you're trying to then manipulate
that as a pure svg
simplified there's a couple of things as
a rule
i use the fewest number of points to
create a shape again
a lot of people will start to
use
point point point point point to try and
get something uh on screen
don't do that try and use the fewest
number of numbers of points
i try to avoid filters in adobe
illustrator as they're not yet
translated into svg with the adobe
illustrator xvg
export so don't tend to do that
don't stroke things if you don't have to
stroking is going to add
another level or layer to svg that you
really don't need if you need it
fine but if you don't make sure it's not
there and
try to keep polygons and circles as
geometrical objects don't try to
break them apart
create a background if necessary
understand that svg
elements are transparent by default
they're automatically off mask that's
awesome
but it means that there's no body to an
svg element there's nothing
there that you can say oh okay i'm just
going to color the background of this
black or whatever it happens to be you
can do that
in the body element of your html page
where the css
sorry where the svg is ultimately going
to be used but you can't do an svg
itself
short of drawing a giant rectangle or
something behind the
whole artboard
you can kind of sort of
do a background on the svg
itself um using as we'll take a look at
this a little bit
you can use um css to create backgrounds
so it's it's possible to do you've just
got to be a little bit careful about how
you do it
finally if if possible before exporting
from illustrator to svg try and merge
shapes
so use pathfinder tools try and merge
them together if possible
again fewer elements simple elements
better doesn't mean the svg can't be
complex doesn't mean it can't involve a
lot of elements
but obviously the fewer things you have
and better
finally decide how you're going to treat
your text
it's important to understand that you
can in
svg have text as text
so it's readable it's styleable it's
everything else
but with the downsides that we've
experienced with
text readable styleable text on the web
forever
that is you might try and load a font
and the font doesn't load
right if you're trying to use a special
kind of font
so that has all the same problems in
that regard or
you can break it apart you can
absolutely break it into outlines
downside of that is you it's not
readable anymore it's purely path
information
you just can't use it that way anymore
so
do try to make a decision about is this
going to be
readable because it is by google by
everything else
then leave it as text style it and
understand that
okay styles might not always be applied
in every circumstance we've got to be
careful with that
or you want it exactly that way but you
don't want it ultimately readable by
anything but you want it manipulable so
you can move
points around and then absolutely break
it convert into outlines
finally crop the outcrop the artboard no
point in having areas that you don't
need
and export to svg one thing to keep in
mind about that
the export for svg
adobe illustrator kind of even adobe
illustrator cc
kind of sort of lies to you it does
allow an export
it absolutely does
but adobe illustrator cc
has this semi-wanted new feature
of make responsive
and it's not totally true it goes part
of the way it removes the height and
width elements which i'll get into a
little bit
but it doesn't really do everything that
you need it to do in most circumstances
so
take the make responsive in option in
svg with a from illustrator with a grain
of salt
um there's a one important point
uh in illustrator to try to
you've got an option to reduce the
number of decimal points
used in as the export
and honestly decimal points are the
position
of each little element the position of
each little point in the svg drawing
you don't need three decimal places for
drawings in the vast majority of
circumstances so
if you can avoid that because all it
does is add file space it just makes the
svg larger and longer
if you possibly can reduce the number of
decimal points to ideally one
all this stuff can ultimately be done
post
processing with some of the tools that
sarah talked about
but why post process something when you
can make sure it's right the first time
so and finally obviously export the file
as an svg treat it as svg
it's all good to go from that point
okay basic svg cleanup
so again sarah was talking a little bit
about
how to make a
svg clean through the nature of
some tools and that's good to know and
that's important it's also really useful
to know
what those tools are actually doing it's
not terribly complicated for the most
part
and if you understand a little bit about
what they're doing then you can
do this by hand if the tool doesn't work
you can understand what might go wrong
things of that nature so there's a
couple of things
generally speaking the export
of an svg document will be from
illustrator from
inkscape from a number of other tools
will be extremely verbose
you'll have a lot of information in
there and
while it's not wrong to have the
information in there
you can usually save yourself quite a
bit of space by doing a couple of things
so first of all note again that this in
this case
has five decimal places for
the um svg
points on the path and again wouldn't be
necessary
i could post process this take them out
but i'm not going to concentrate on that
for right
now okay things you don't need you
honestly don't need in the vast majority
of cases unless you're doing
some sort of of deep deep dive with xml
you don't need the xml prologue you
don't need the doctype
you don't just don't need them you do
need the xml ns
namespacing stuff mostly for the fact
that without it it's not going to be
valid
so you may as well leave it in version
you don't technically need
width and height width and height are
the things that
for the most part um get people a little
bit screwed up because they
they think that what's constraining this
thing is
the width and height or the view box
take the view box out they get confused
between the two so i'll explain what's
going on there
for right now take it out notice that
nothing actually changed
uh you don't need id on the svg element
itself unless you're doing a whole bunch
of work
a whole bunch of svgs on the same page
so again take that out
everything's fine don't need id
at the same time of course make sure
that it's still valid make sure that
everything is still working
don't need deaths very often unless it's
defining a filter or some other stuff
do be careful about group transforms
you'll very often find
empty groups so groups that don't
actually do anything
google group just jeebs if they don't do
anything they can usually be removed
if there are groups with ideas if
they're groups with transforms on them
leave them the heck alone you don't want
to play around with them because
otherwise
removing them or changing will always
spoil your work
then there's a whole bunch of stuff in
there here's where it gets interesting
okay so i started off talking about the
fact that um
svg um and and css
are really copacetic they're really
buddies they're not fighting against
each other so let me demonstrate a
couple of ways
that's true you can see that by default
most tools will put a lot of the styles
for this stuff
in line it doesn't need to be in line
at all it does need to have a path sorry
an
id but it doesn't need to be in line at
all you can do the self same stuff that
you've always
been used to and work with by doing an
embedded style tag
inside the css and that style tag
can absolutely contain the vast majority
of the css that you used to it can
contain media queries
it can contain hovers it can contain
most of the stuff they used to again
sarah did a very nice little screen
of here's what um the
page will take here's what it won't take
so there are some exceptions but for the
most part every every
piece of css you used to can actually be
applied
here's where it gets interesting so our
path has an id of path one let's just
change that
let's just call that jedi okay
so it has an id if it has an id it can
be addressed like an id
or a class or most anything else that
you're used to
it can be addressed as an id just like
anything else right it's a fragment so
it's a piece on a page it's part of the
dom
the really interesting part is this
stuff
can get used as part of that style
we don't need even on we don't need
stroke in this case
all right
okay so what's happening
essentially we can take many
not all but many of the style attributes
from svg and apply them as styles
in css that starts to make things really
neat and really interesting
what it means is that you can use
any css color in this case
associated with that style
right so it means that you can
have immediate manipulation of this now
people get a little confused often
students i teach get a little confused
the first time i show
them this because they say but but
there's no fill
property does that mean i can now go on
to my normal html set page and say
dev phil red no you can't it's only
applicable to svg
but within the context of svg it's
perfectly understood and perfectly
reasonable
um so the the really interesting part is
that
all of the css the absolute all the css
that you know can absolutely be applied
so if we say let's say hsl
hsla goodness sake
and we say okay 100
50 percent 50
comma 0.3
okay so yeah any hsl
any colors any kinds of things that you
want to apply you can absolutely do
it doesn't mean that you have to stick
with hex if you want to stick with x
that's perfectly fine
this opacity okay so svg has a thing
called opacity
for obvious reasons or fill opacity but
you can do opacity
in however you want to set it up in just
the way that you wouldn't css right it's
it's a css thing so now we can use css
directly
on our svg
okay you can do hover effects
inside your svg just using css so if you
say
let's say
hover over that element okay it's got an
id hover over it
let's say we want to do a partial fade
okay now there's a couple of interesting
things to note about that and of course
yeah you can transition
as well right
let me push that down all the way down
to zero
so yeah it fades in it fades out so you
can absolutely do
all the interface stuff that you're used
to in css3
applied to svg there's a couple of
interesting things to note about this
svg is defined by shapes if svg is
defined by
shapes it's not the box model you used
to in the sense that
you'll notice that if this was a picture
like a ping
in normal circumstances as soon as you
move over the
area of the thing right the rectangular
box that contains it
then this thing's going to activate
right but in
svg that doesn't count it really only
looks at the shape
so i have to be over that shape before
anything happens
and that starts mean very very precise
pixel responses
we've all seen icons big rectangular
icons with circular shapes inside
and the problem is you move over the
rectangular outside area and the circle
turns on or clicks or does whatever it's
going to do
and it's a misregistration in svg one of
its real advantages is there is no
misregistration
if you make a shape and you say this
shape is a link or the shape has a hover
effect or the shape has whatever
that's the shape and that's what
registers which makes it really really
powerful and very very good
okay so that's your basic svg cleanup
that's
and some of the ways in which you can
start to use css
practically i'm just saying okay i've
got this svg i want to make it hover
the one thing i i should mention the one
thing you have to be aware of
is that css written inside the svg
it will affect the appearance of the svg
but not as interactivity in other words
you can't write a hover rule
inside an svg and then take that svg as
an
image and put it on the page as image
here's my svg as inside your html page
the the appearance will work but the
interactivity won't
um if you want the interactivity you've
got to move it either as an
object or as a typically increasingly
just as a flat svg street inside the
html you just
bunk it inside the html and then you get
all the interactivity you get everything
else
so you've got to be a little bit careful
about okay i can write rules
absolutely but those rules won't
necessarily
translate interactive wise
into the svg as an as an actual image
but svg straight on the page absolutely
well
okay so a surprising number of people
in the conference that we've just been
attending
don't know about svg filters
or using filters in general there was a
quick little hand up and very few people
were using them
and that's surprising to me because one
of the things that we're talking about
increasingly is okay we want to get
pages loaded as quickly as possible we
want to have interactivity as snappy as
possible we want to
not have a lot of work to make things
happen we don't want to have to do
multiple things in our workflow so
traditionally with filters people think
of filters with webkit
and and understandably so because
filters in webkit they've been in there
for a couple of years now and people say
hey they're really neat
and it's it's totally true you can
absolutely
while they went through a couple of
changes in terms of the spec
yeah you can absolutely do filters
in that way but not too many people know
that the same filters were also built
into ie
up into ie um
eight right uh i'll talk a little bit
about ie
um 10 and 11 and so on so forth in a
second
and very often they were really simple
stuff like that
sorry stuff like this so all right so
you have
um safari and at least modern safari and
modern chrome covered with the
modern web kilt css3 thing that
unfortunately other browsers haven't
great
yet you have um
ie up to nine covered by
grace uh the gray scale filter what do
you do about firefox well
in firefox you can
add a tiny tiny little svg file
and that svg file is sort of the same
excuse
that svg file is like the world's
simplest svg it's tiny
um in this case to be fair it's a color
matrix
um the the nice thing about this is
you really don't need to understand it
totally it's it's matrix math
um it's no big deal uh but you pop it
into a page
or you can pop it in as a separate file
if you want to but it's
so tiny i usually pop it straight into
the page okay
what does it do very simply it's a bit
of
svg that essentially does the same
filter job
so
that filter grayscale filter url
grayscale because it looks at the id
right in this case it had the filter has
an id of grayscale
so i use it here and it does the exact
same job in firefox
and the nice part about this is that you
now have
the same effect and it's one of the
really good um
examples of progressive enhancement
unless you or your client are a real
stickler for
everything has to look exactly the same
way generally speaking people aren't
going to be hugely upset
if they're in ie 10 for instance
and if they don't know that the thing is
meant to be black and white and then
transitioning into color later and they
just see a color
version because ie10 is a between a rock
and a hard place it doesn't yet support
the web simply the webkit css3 style
filters it doesn't do the svg filters at
least in this way so unfortunately it's
in a rocky place at the moment
but if they don't they're not aware of
that then that's fine
the advantage is you load one image once
you want to turn it into svg so you want
to turn it into grayscale
that's that's perfectly fine you add you
add a filter and it's done
you don't have to load multiple versions
of the image you don't have to have
multiple http requests you don't have to
do weird things with image sprites
they're just done so it's it's nice it
makes a whole lot of sense to me
you could do the same things same idea
with things like blur
again uh traditional
microsoft blur filters okay so a8
et cetera et cetera
modern blur filters in terms of webkit
and blur in terms of svg
and you can transition the things as
well so yeah you can absolutely have
blur on and off
uh sepia toning totally possible as well
uh let me think ramon here very quickly
because i'm i'm almost out of time
uh a couple of other areas in which
people don't necessarily understand that
svg can start to be used
image maps for anybody who's been around
on the web for
10 years plus will remember image maps
and they they went in kind of the way of
the dodo they're not responsive they
were grabbing these big glad images
but they still do have their place they
were actually really good
for touch screens because especially for
kids because they could see them and
they could touch them touch the pictures
and navigate away from there
problem wise they're not responsive at
all traditional image maps can't be
svg you can absolutely make responsive
image maps because you can make svg
responsive you can put an image bitmap
image in the background
and that hotspot will exactly scale with
the image as it moves up and down
which is really neat
animated mesh maps
using clip areas uh you can
clip out bitmap photographs using paths
and svg
you can then again because it's perfect
pixel pixel perfect registration
you can start to both link those areas
and animate them inside had an article
on net magazine a couple of months ago
about that same technique if you want to
read up on it
perhaps most fun adaptive illustration
so adaptive illustrations are the idea
that you can do media queries
inside of svg
so a lot of traditional kinds
of use of svg
is and responsive design is making
things smaller
again nothing wrong with making things
smaller rearranging them
placing them in different orders that's
perfectly fine what's
somewhat unexplored i think is the
concept
of well we we don't just need to make
things smaller
we could also do things like as an
example
starting to remove components
and you can remove components you can
see the top there
you can see other components moving
outside of this
because each fragment is identifiable
inside that svg so you can absolutely
remove them using media queries and
simplify
designs not just
don't have the space and no one's going
to zoom in and out it's all kinds of
really wonderful possibilities there
very finally the
css spec for gradients is meant to have
animation
it's meant to do it unfortunately it
doesn't no
no one to my knowledge no one supports
it yet which is really really
unfortunate
however svg has supported animated
gradients for
ages forever so
you can start to do really really
interesting work
but this comes up
by uh animating the actual gradients
you have to use um animate tags inside
of svg and
they're not too dissimilar to
the concept of transitions so it takes a
little bit of getting used to but it's
not too
too terribly dissimilar so you can
finally this is a
basic sky 24-hour skype animation
you can finally start to animate
gradients which is wonderful
and there's a lot in there and
eventually of course this will be
supported
in css but if you need it right now you
want an animated gradient
do it in svg absolutely so that's all
the time i have
i hope this was helpful again if you
have follow-up questions
by all means ask me on twitter follow up
on the blog and i hope to do a
fuller and more complete a-track
presentation in future
css course thanks very much
you